you know I think I'm gonna have a drink
for this one good good good good good
good afternoon everyone welcome to
better than for book reviews this is no
time for making jokes we're reviewing a
JM Coetzee novel today anyways great to
see you as always
hope you're all doing well it's a
beautiful day here in Detroit Michigan
and it seems inappropriate to be talking
about a book this dark on a day that's
nice but the show must go on and it's a
damn good book so today is JM coatsy's
disgrace it's a disgrace that it took me
this long to read code see this is my
first one but upon finishing this one
good Lord God how does he do it is the
first question I ask
it's a strikingly perfect balance of
brutal gut-wrenching metaphysical terror
in the form of a page-turner how do you
make a book this dark this readable not
necessarily palatable as it's effective
right in communicating the darkness
depressing sometimes though always
honest and beautiful not overwrought or
dishonest or self pitying not at all but
again a page-turner
I mean it grips you and you're going I
mean it's it's something about his word
choice and economy and his knowledge of
the language is balance of the sentences
it's what what is it what do we got here
as far as page count we got 200 215 it's
not a long novel
it's excellent so I mean really I'm
going to shorter novels I know I need to
read the big ones and all the good stuff
like brothers Kay and yeah I'll get to
Louis's and all that stuff and but I
mean really you know if you the the
fewer pages you can use to get an idea
across a really heavy idea or just a
just some great questions I mean the
more effective the more impressive it is
to me personally especially now because
everything's vying for our time you know
I think a take a friend a friend and I
were talking about this a while ago we
were just talking about shorter novels
and how much more
you know how things are going that way
I'm not necessarily opposed to it you
know of course if there's nothing wrong
with longer books it's just it's just a
question of time and efficiency really
you know especially what the culture not
being very reading oriented these days
maybe I don't know this is I guess
that's up for debate but it's different
this is a story about an English
professor in cake tenon who teaches
bored students about the Romantic poets
in literature
he's an expert in byron spoilers coming
he sleeps with one of his students a
young girl I think she's 20 or something
like that the book is told through his
point of view and he says he doesn't
rape her but the coercion and lack of
enthusiasm on her part seems enough to
suggest a comparison with what's to come
which I will tell you so again
spoiler alert spoiler alert it's very
difficult to talk about this one without
giving you giving away what happens in
the plot you know because it's it's it's
it's fundamental to discussing it you
know sort of operating on a couple of
major major major scenes so the
relationship is discovered he refuses to
apologize for his nature to the board or
the committee or whoever and is
subsequently kicked out ostracized from
the academic world there's actually a
great moment of him giving a lecture on
Lucifer well after he's done what he's
done the fall from grace right see
Paradise Lost so that part of his life
is over I mean he's 52 you know it's
it's a very very you could say bold move
on his part to not even I mean all these
people try and get him to apologize to
take back what he's done but he's like
no like I did it I take full
responsibility I'm totally accountable
now punish me like sentence me do what
you're gonna do let's get on with our
lives and and so they do and so he just
splits that part of his life is over now
so he decides to go visit his lesbian
daughter who lives on a rural farm with
a black neighbor who helps her out named
Petrus an older guy
this is South Africa so apartheid is in
its history there is a feeling of racial
tension so all of that influences this
narrative so he works at a local animal
shelter
his daughter's friend euthanizing dogs
dogs are an integral piece of the book
sort of a metaphor going and selling
produce at the farmers market helping it
out you know and he hopes to get working
on writing an opera about Byron so while
he's visiting two black men and a boy
break into his daughter's house lock him
in the bathroom so he's unable to help
her rape her then douse him in alcohol
and set him on fire he and his daughter
survived though the physical wounds
aren't nearly as damaging as the
psychological his daughter becomes
despondent and indifferent to just about
everything she doesn't report it to the
police even though he insists like
demands it even because of well many
things it seems and this is where
everything gets truly complex and
painful and bleak as if it wasn't enough
already
Lucy even suggests that her rape is
similar to paying taxes it's like what
the men believe they're owed for her
being in their environment you know in
that landscape as a white person as a
white woman she isn't justifying it
she's just it's like an argument that
she pauses and it's it's kind of just so
demint it's just that sound comes out a
lot when you're reading this book like
she suggests in almost in this kind of
like some sort of like just a truly dark
space that that's just that's just the
way things work there or something you
know it's like this is this is
historical retribution or this is kind
of uh now that whites aren't on top
right now that they're the minority this
is how things work around there or
something and this is the unspoken law
in order for her to exist in this
environment something akin to that which
of course to us and the father our main
character david luery is just
devastating I mean I don't yeah if
there's no other word for it
there are so many questions and so few
answers in this book that it I mean it's
part of its brilliance and I mean he
knows what he's doing but but but he
doesn't
tell you Betty has the answers because I
don't think he does and neither do we
you know although we may feel very very
strongly that we do certainly I know
what I would do in the situation or I
have a feeling I know what I would do in
this situation and I assume the feeling
is probably mutual we all want her to
report it we want justice done we all
want these things to work out okay even
though everything has gone to absolute
hell and further but yeah I mean can you
imagine I mean just the fact that he's
like like he's just unable to it's just
about failure in every sense like
failure to save his daughter failure to
to just failure [__] endless failure
god things can always get worse him
there's one more enormous cataclysmic
event to top things off but I've told
you enough I'll leave it for you to find
out you've you've you've this is plenty
for now this is a book about failure on
so many levels you know when he wants to
when he finally starts writing his opera
I just thought this was a so brutal but
beautiful here and it starts off with he
sighs it would have been nice to be
returned to triumphant to society as the
author of an eccentric little chamber
opera but that will not be his hopes
must be more temperate that somewhere
from amidst the welter of sound there
will dart up like a bird a single
authentic note of immortal longing as
for recognizing it he will leave that to
the scholars of the future if there are
still scholars by then for he will not
hear the note himself when it comes if
it comes he knows too much about art in
the ways of art to expect that though it
would have been nice for Lucy to hear
proof in her lifetime and think a little
better of him he just like drives it in
like a knife
he's got man he wields the pen like a
sword coatsy is a master master one of
the greatest authors alive he has to be
he won the Nobel Prize coatsy was born
in Cape Town but
he was educated in part in Texas he grew
up in South Africa he's an academic who
taught at Johns Hopkins Stanford Harvard
University of Chicago in the University
of Capetown influenced by Kafka is also
a fan of Beckett and Joyce and their
grasp and mastery of the English
language
Joyce particularly in his ulysses phase
I think yeah it's near-perfect writing
right if there is such a thing balanced
clear smooth easy and enjoyable to read
it's like a perfect glass of wine you
know it when you come across it right
you don't even notice it it's like it's
like a perfect film because you know the
whole thing with film is that you don't
notice that it's a film it just it just
rolls and rolls and rolls and we're good
same thing with literature you just jump
in and you don't eat you don't question
it you know you're not aware that you're
reading you know who is it Elmore
Leonard says if it sounds like writing I
rewrite it yeah
little is definitive in this one other
than nobody wins whatsoever and there's
no hope well I suppose there's hope but
I mean you could you could probably
argue that one ultra tragic so sad it's
not a character struggling against the
curse of existence only to be torn apart
but rather a person who sort of has a
good idea of their own failures and
takes responsibility for them much of
the tension between the characters has
to do with the political history of
South Africa and apartheid something I
know nothing about so I'm really going
off the basic idea that apartheid
happened it was bad it's no longer
around but there are lingering
aftershocks
and like many places including here the
present is haunted by the past regarding
Dostoevsky skepticism that the self
could ever tell the truth to itself this
interviewer asks Coetzee why is
self-delusion so apparently inescapable
they're discussing the difference
between Rousseau believing that you just
need to be completely honest referencing
his confessions I haven't read it and
then comparing that to Dostoevsky x'
view that it's not just good enough to
look in your heart and write and that it
just as well maybe some self-serving lie
as it is to be the truth about yourself
as coatsy tells us and coatsy says he
falls in line with Dostoevsky I think
that the basis of his position is simply
that the heart of our own desire is
unknown
to us and perhaps even further that it's
in the nature of human desire not to
know itself fully to have some kernel of
the unknowable in it and perhaps that is
what animates desire namely that it is
unknowable to itself what is self
delusional is to imagine that you can
tell the truth about yourself that it
merely takes you know a certain
frankness with oneself in a certain
boldness and putting it down on paper
and revealing it to other people that is
at least in Dostoevsky XY's a delusion
how much of that he agrees with I'm not
so sure but he seems to agree with all
of it I don't know what do you think do
you agree with that do you think we're
able to accurately assess our own
behavior and tell the truth the actual
truth or is there no truth is it like
Pirandello's character composed of one
no one and one hundred thousand truths
depending on who you're interacting with
is that the truth that there's an
unfathomable different shades of truth
which is to say maybe that there is no
truth at all I'm asking you this is one
of the best I've read this year better
than food by far loved it
terrific not a happy book but a
beautiful book in its own way so you
should read it if you enjoyed stoner by
John Williams definitely also a sad
story about an academic feel like
William Faulkner you know I did Absalom
Absalom another sad story about family
and I struggled by canals guard
definitely definitely check this out
maybe if you enjoyed Michelle well back
or a saline although there's no malice
in coatsy's writing I think those two
previously mentioned definitely have a
lot more cynicism there's there's not
much cynicism going on and disgrace it's
pretty sincere so there's gonna get it
for the coffee lottery for those of you
who are new to the coffee lottery is
where I take all the names of the
patrons on patreon who donated five
dollars or more to support the show and
I place their names in this mason jar I
pull out a name for every review I do
and I send whoever's name I pull out a
hard copy of the book I'm reviewing
along with a bag of coffee roasted by
yours truly and the coffee is delicious
got a shipment of Guatemalan recently
drinking it all the time love it if you
are interested in getting in on that you
can head over to the description box
below and click on the link or head over
to patreon comm for SI books better than
food and donate five dollars or more per
video and one dollar or more will get
you access to patron only reviews I
sincerely appreciate it thank you to
everybody to the support of the show and
best of luck to you so here we go
[Music]
really appreciate it always remember
bring a book wherever you go you never
know and you'll have a few minutes to
read you may finish more books than you
thought you could with the amount of
time that you have then that would be
great
please subscribe if you haven't already
for more book reviews I also do film
reviews some good stuff coming your way
soon please hit the thumbs up if you
enjoyed this always helps and if you
like to you can follow me on Instagram
take care of yourselves have a good
night and I'll talk to you soon ciao